let me ask you um mention autopilot
gotta ask you about tesla
this renegade little company that seems
to be from my perspective
revolutionizing autonomous driving or
semi-autonomous driving or at least the
problem of
perception and control
they've got a semi on the way
they got a truck on the way what are
your thoughts about tesla semi you know
i am and i did have
some very preliminary conversations with
um
with uh you know policy folks there um
you know nothing really in
the tech or business side of it too much
um and here's why i think because
electrification and autonomy run in
opposite directions right um and i just
you know um i don't see the application
the value in self-driving for the truck
that tesla is going to produce in the
near term
um you know they're just you're not
going to have the battery um now you
could have wonderful safety systems and
you know reinforcing you know the auto
you know self-driving features
supporting a skilled driver
but you're not going to be able to pull
that driver out for long stretches the
way that you are with driverless trucks
so
do you think
i mean the reason so that yeah the the
electrification
uh is not obviously coupled with the
automation
[Music]
they have a very interesting approach to
semi-autonomous
pushing towards autonomous driving
right it's very unique
no lidar
now no radar
it's computer vision alone
from a large they're collecting huge
amounts of data from a large fleet it's
an interesting unique approach
bold and fearless in this direction if i
were to guess
whether this approach would work i would
say
no
it started
one you would need wait a lot of data
and two
because you have actual cars deployed on
the road using
a beta version of this product you're
going to
have a system that's
far less safe you're going to run into
trouble it's horrible pr like it just
seems like a nightmare
but it seems to not be the case at least
up to this point it seems to be uh not
you know
on par if not safer and it seems to work
really well and human the human factor
somehow
manages
like drivers still pay attention now
there's a selection of who is inside the
tesla autopilot
user base right there could be a
self-selection mechanism there but
however it works
these things are not running off the
road all the time
so it's very interesting whether that
can sort of creep into the trucking
space
yes
at first the long-haul problem
is not solved they need to charge but
maybe you can solve you know a lot of
your scenarios involved
small
distances
and you know that last mile
aspect which is exactly what tesla is
trying to solve for the
hum for the
for the regular uh passenger vehicle uh
space is the city driving it's possible
that you have these trucks
it's it's almost like
yeah you you solve the uh the last mile
delivery part of some of the scenarios
that you mentioned
in autonomous driving space is that
do you think that's from the people
you've spoken with too difficult of a
problem the the thing that you know
keeps me
so interested in this space and thinking
that it's so important you know is is
again that
that efficiency question that safety
question and the and the way that these
economics can push us potentially you
know toward a more efficient system so i
want to see those tesla electric trucks
running out to those truck ports where
you're where you've got those two you
know um two trucks with a human driver
in front
right um you know i think that's now
what's powering those is that hydrogen
you know i mean i don't you know again
it's very interesting as a researcher
who does not have a background in
technology and doesn't have a
have a horse you know in this in this
race i mean you know for all i know
self-driving trucks will ultimately be
achieved by some biomechanical sensor
that uses echolocation because we took
stem cells of bats and you know i mean i
don't you know i i don't i i'm
completely um
unable to assess who's you know who's
that or who's behind her who makes sense
but but i think one key component there
and this is what i see with tesla often
and it's it's quite sad to me that other
companies don't do this enough
is is that first principles thinking
like wait wait okay it's looking at the
inefficiencies as opposed to
i worked with quite a few car companies
and they basically have a lot of
meetings there's a lot of meetings
and the discussion is like how can we
make this cheaper this cheaper this
cheaper this component cheaper this
cheaper
the cheapification of everything just
like you said as opposed to saying wait
a minute let's step back
let's look at the entirety of the
inefficiencies in the system
like why have we been doing this like
this for the last few decades
like start from scratch can this be 10x
100x cheaper like if we not just
decrease the the cost of one component
here this component here or this
component here but like
let's like redesign everything let's uh
infrastructure let's have special lanes
or in terms of truck ports as opposed to
having regular human control truck ports
have some kind of weird
like like sensors like where everything
about the truck uh connecting at that
final destination is automated fully
from the ground up you build the
facility from the ground up for the
autonomous truck um all all those kinds
of sort of questions or platooning let's
say wait a minute okay
i know we think platooning is hard but
can we think through exactly why it's
hard and can we actually solve it like
if we collect a huge amount of data can
we solve it
and then tell the operation
like okay yeah yeah it's difficult to
have good signal but can we actually can
we have can we consider the the the
probability of those edge cases and what
to do in the edge cases when the tail
operation fails like how difficult is
this what are the costs how do we
actually construct a uh tele operation
center full of humans that are able to
pay attention to a large fleet where the
average number of vehicles per human is
like 10 or 100
you know like
having that conversation as opposed to
kind of
having you know you show up to work and
say all right
it seems like uh you know because of
covid we you know are not making as much
money can we have a cheaper can we give
less salary to the trucker and can we uh
build like uh um
decrease the cost or
decrease the frequency at which we buy
new trucks
and when we do buy new trucks make them
cheaper by making them crappier like
this kind of discussion this is why to
me it's like tesla is like rare on this
and so there's some sectors in which
innovation is part of the culture
in the automotive sector for some reason
it's not as much
um this is obviously the problem that
ford and gm are struggling with it's
like they're really good at making cars
at scale cheap
and they're like legit good like toyota
at this some of the greatest
manufacturing people in the world right
that's incredible but then
when it comes to hiring software people
they're horrible so
it's culture and then it's such a
difficult thing for them to sort of
embrace but greatness requires that they
embrace this
embrace whatever is required to remove
the inefficiency from the system and
that may require you to do things very
differently that you've done in the past
yeah i mean there are certain
things that the market can do well in my
you know this is how i see the world
right um is you know and there
that's the best way to to to organize
certain kinds of activities is the
market and and private interest
but i i think we go
too far in in some areas um
transportation is if we can't
have a public debate about
the roads that we all pay for
um
forget about it private factories and
you know all these other you know
healthcare and other places it's going
to be way harder um there uh healthcare
i guess has some you know some some uh
some direct contact with the consumer
where we're probably gonna have lots of
um sort of hands-on public policy about
you know concerns around patient rights
and things like that but
if we can't figure out how to have a
public policy conversation around how
technology is going to reform our public
you know roadways and our transportation
system like we're you know we're really
leaving way too much to private
companies it's just it's not it's not in
there
i get asked this question like what
should companies do and like you know
just go about doing what you're doing
you know i mean please come to the table
and talk about it but it's not their
role i mean i appreciate you know
uh elon's you know attempts to sort of
you know have species level goals you
know like oh you know we're going to go
to mars i mean that's amazing
and that's incredible that that someone
can realize you know that you know
have a chance at realizing that vision
it's amazing right but
when it comes to so many areas of our
economy you know we can't wait for a
hero um you know we we have to have and
they're way too many interests involved
you know it's who builds the roads who
you know i mean the the money that
sloshes around on capitol hill to decide
what happens in in these infrastructure
bills and the transportation bill is
just obscene
right see i think this is an interesting
view of markets
correct me if i'm wrong let me let me
propose a theory to you
that progress in the world is made by
heroes and the markets remove the
inefficiencies from the work the heroes
did
so going to mars from the perspective of
markets
probably has no value maybe you can
argue it's good for hiring to have a
vision or something like that but like
those big projects don't seem to have an
obvious value but
world
our world progresses by those big leaps
and then as after the leaps are taken
then the markets are very good at uh
removing sort of inefficiencies but it
just feels like the autonomous vehicle
space and the autonomous trucking space
requires leaps
it doesn't feel like we can sneak up
into a good solution that is ultimately
good for labor like for human beings in
the system it feels like some
like uh
probably a bad example but like a henry
four type of character steps in and said
like we need to do stuff completely
differently
um
yeah and i
you said you we can't hope for a hero
but it's like no but we can say we need
a hero we need more heroes so if you're
a young kid right now listening to this
we need you to be a hero it's not like
we need you to start a company that
makes a lot of money no you need to
start a company that makes a lot of
money so that you can
feed your family as you become a hero
and take huge risks and potentially go
bankrupt
those risks is how we move society
forward i think maybe there's a romantic
view i don't know i totally disagree you
disagree god damn it i mean i and the
two of us
you're the knowledgeable one no no um no
no i i think it's a it's a matter of
like do we need those heroes absolutely
i mean i i i saw the you know um the
boosters come down from spacex's rockets
and you know
land nearly simultaneously with my kids
um you know after school one day
and i thought
oh my god like this is
like science fiction has been been made
real it's incredible and and it's a
pinnacle of human achievement right it's
like this is what we're capable of
but we need to have
that those heroes oriented we we need to
allow them
right to orient toward the right um
toward the goals right we got it climate
change
you know i mean
all the heroes out there
right i mean it's time it's time the
clock is ticking it's pat it's it's past
time i've been working on climate change
issues since
you know the mid 90s
like i i still remember um the first
time in 2010 when i got a grant to that
was completely focused on adaptation
rather than prevention
and just when it when it hit me
that like
wow
like so that versus prevention is like
acceptance that
yeah there's going to be catastrophic
impact we just need we need to figure
out how do we at least live with that
yeah and and you know the grant was like
okay our agriculture system is going to
move our bread basket is no longer going
to be california it's going to be
illinois what does that mean for truck
transportation so it's like uh
so
in terms of a big philosophical societal
level that's kind of like giving up yeah
in terms of the big heroic actions yeah
you know failures in human history
yeah that's going to be
let's hope not the biggest but
could be
do you so so but let me say why i
disagree right um
henry ford amazing right to sort of mass
produce cars right daimler to put that
first truck on the road
without the roads right so there's like
we need that innovation there's no doubt
about it and there's r there are rules
for that but there's big public stuff
um that that that sets the stage that's
critical and and you know and what it
really is it's a it's a social
sociological problem right it's a
political problem it's a social problem
we have to say and we have these screwed
up ideas right so we have this politics
right now where like everybody feels
like they're getting screwed and someone
undeserving is you know
is benefiting when in fact like you know
at least in the middle right they're
huge i i used to teach this course in
rich and poor you know in economic
inequality and i would go through you
know public housing subsidies in
philadelphia um you know section 8
subsidies um you know
and then i would go through
my housing subsidies for my
mortgage interest deduction
and it worked out to basically the
average payment for
a section 8 housing voucher in my
neighborhood i'm not a welfare recipient
according to the dominant discourse and
so we have this completely screwed up
sense of like where our dollars go and
you know where the who benefits from the
investment and
you know we need to you know we
i don't know that we can do it but you
know if we're gonna
survive we need to figure out how to
have honest conversations where private
interest
is where we need it to be in fostering
innovation and and you know and
rewarding the people who do incredible
things please you know we we don't want
to squash that
but we need to harness that power to
solve what i think are some pretty big
you know existential problems so you
think there's a like government level
national level collaboration required
for infrastructure projects like
there's we should really
have
large moonshot projects that uh are
funded by
our governments
at least guided by i mean i think there
are ways to finance them and you know
other things but we we
got to be careful right because that
that's where you get all these sort of
perverse you know unintended
consequences and whatnot but if you look
at transportation yeah in the united
states and it is the foundation of of
the the you know manifest destiny
economic growth right that that built
the united states into the the world
superpower that it became and the
industrial power that it became it
rested on transportation right it was
like you know the erie canal i i grew up
a few miles from where they dug the
first shovel full of the erie canal and
everyone thought it was you know crazy
right um but those public infrastructure
projects the the canals right the
railroads yeah they were privately built
but they wouldn't have been privately
built without you know lincoln funding
them essentially and giving you know the
railroads you know land um in exchange
for building them um the highway system
the the eisenhower the the payback that
the u.s economy got from the dwight d
eisenhower interstate system is
phenomenal
right um no private entity was going to
do that electrification
dams water you know
we we need to do this infrastructure
yeah infrastructure and now more than
ever it's been really upsetting to me on
on the covet front
um there's
one of the solutions to kovid which
seems obvious to me from the very
beginning that nobody's opposed to
it's one of the only bipartisan things
is
at home testing rapid at home testing
there's no reason
why at the government level we couldn't
manufacture hundreds of millions of
tests a month there's no reason starting
in may 2020
and that gives power
to a country that values freedom that
gives power information to each
individual to know whether they have
coveted or not
so
uh
it's possible to manufacture them for
under a dollar
it's like an obvious thing it's kind of
like the roads it's like everybody's
invested let's put
countless tests in the hands of every
single american citizen maybe every
citizen of the world
the fact that we haven't done that
today and there's some regulation stuff
with the fda all the kind of
dragging of feet but there's not
actually a good explanation except
our leaders
and culturally we've lost the sort of uh
not lost but it's a little bit dormant
the will to do these big projects that
better the world
i still have the hope that when faced
with
uh catastrophic events
the the more dramatic the more damaging
the more painful they are the higher we
will rise to meet those
and that's where the infrastructure
style projects are really important but
it's certainly um
a little bit challenging to remain an
optimist in the times of covid
because the response of our leaders has
not been as great and as historic as i
would have
hoped
i i would hope that the actions of
leaders in the past few years in
response to kovid
would be ones that are written in the
history books and we talk about as we
talk about fdr
but sadly i don't know i think the
history books will forget this resp
the actions of our leaders
you